Hi, my name is Chris Gagne and I'm an Agile coach.
Today, I will talk about I.N.V.E.S.T.
I.N.V.E.S.T. is a mnemonic that helps us remember a good starting point for the Definition of Ready.
The Definition of Ready is a documented team agreement.
It defines the conditions that must be met for a product backlog item to be considered ready to work on by the team.
It's not a formal contract or approval gate
but rather a set of guidelines that will help your team make a good trade-off between
minimizing risks and getting started.
Creating and following the Definition of Ready diligently can easily double the speed of an Agile team.
That's because the team can stay focused on shipping working software not chasing down requirements.
For a real-world example, think of the "mise en place" or "everything in its place" concept used by chefs and cooking shows.
Before they begin preparing the recipe, they carefully organize and measure the various ingredients
so they're immediately at hand while cooking.
A little careful preparation goes a long way
So what's I.N.V.E.S.T?
Well, I like to add a "U" in front for U.-I.N.V.E.S.T but you don't have to.
"U" stands for "User Experience" which includes everything from research,
wireframes, mocks, written content, and even visual design.
Now mature Scrum teams with dedicated designers
can research,
design, code, test, and ship within
a single two week sprint.
If you can't, consider making "User Experience" a prerequisite for development work beginning.
"I" means "Independent."
The backlog item should be self-contained in a way that there is no in sprint dependency
on another backlog item.
"N" means "Negotiable."
Until the Sprint formally starts, the development team and product owner can negotiate
on the nature and scope of the item.
Once the Sprint starts, the product owner should not materially change the acceptance criteria.
"V" means "Valuable."
A backlog item must deliver value to the stakeholders.
If you can't clearly articulate the value for the work,
you shouldn't do it.
"E" means "Estimable."
The team must be able to estimate the size of the backlog item ideally using story points.
Otherwise, you won't be able to effectively manage
your flow of work
"S" means "Small."
Ideally, the backlog item should not take the team more than half a sprint to complete.
"T" means "Testable."
The backlog item should include enough information to make test development possible.
For instance, "the coffee should be between 120 and 130 degrees Fahrenheit"
is a clear acceptance criteria than
"the coffee should be hot."
Well now you know what I.N.V.E.S.T is!
Go create a Definition of Ready with your team.